este Salvador Dali pay Roberto pour me
more fun artist a surrealist Astaire so
Davido des porta supreme okay romp a con
todo el delito segunda Lydia furious
event a Dionysiac o elderly a vida de
dólar ease me in a crucial Iman our Kiko
evil fever de toda la Costas como
siempre rich Alicia Auto Prado monarchy
no political mentor me Dow Museum in st.
Petersburg has been called the most
comprehensive Museum of Dali in the
world it was started in 1982 and grows
out of a phenomenal private collection
collected by some American Midwest
industrialists Eleanor and Reynolds
Morse I grew up with the collection and
my parents amassed in the house in
Beachwood in the 40s and 50s and 60s
before they they finally move the
collection down here this collection
consists of about a hundred paintings
and then drawings sculptures illustrated
books amounted to another two thousand
works our store is a very commercial
endeavor our visitors enter through the
store they have their wonderful docent
tour of the collection and then they
exit through the store hopefully and in
this way they're able to buy something
and actually extend their experience of
the artwork past the walls of the museum
Dali would love that years back he
produced a a print that was sold at
Sears Roebuck and he thought that was
the greatest thing because it was his
art going to the masses he loved
commerce he loved he would have loved
the idea of people buying his works he
loved the tension and it was so easy to
do antics and get attention and guess
what as a fringe benefit
that I'm gonna call it a pure luck
fringe benefit it turned out to be a
brilliant marketing strategy when Dali
would do something it always seemed to
catch some press so a lot of the
advertising companies like that idea
happy problems but he wanted office
guarantee alka-seltzer shots into the
stomach
she neutralizes that bad it says he was
different than a lot of his other
Surrealists and that he was more
flamboyant and more aggressive that way
than some of the others you know Anna
came from a different school of thought
that has bertone put it Aveda dollars
was out he anagram Dolly's name because
he was always looking for money but he
prospered and continued on or a lot of
the other ones you know didn't continue
on after that I think there was an era
when being highly successful as an
artist made you suspect major art
suspect his reaction to his critics he
probably didn't really do care about you
know what their reaction was when I was
going through school we were not shown
Dali he was not part of the Canon yes we
would buy posters we could find his
images but largely he was not part of
the serious discussion of values which
is what constitutes serious art I think
that has changed
Dali has been reintroduced into the
Canon of the dozen or two dozen most
important artists of our era people
understand that having financial rewards
may be directly relational to the value
of what you're producing dolly has shown
us that that's true you love doing these
crazy things anyway he loved the
attention he got from doing them and now
everybody knows about Dali and they're
interested in his art it's like win win
win win there's no loss there